people of the internet's retro recontour
here welcome back to another let's play
series today we are jumping into death's
door a new title from acid nerve being
published by devolver digital a lot of
people out there have been wondering is
this on game pass is it coming to game
pass because no unfortunately it is not
on game pass right now is it coming
maybe at some point in the future right
now it's only on xbox and pc uh and it
is 20 bucks you can get it on steam
i'm here to tell you i highly recommend
you if you're on the fence just go ahead
and buy this game support the developers
don't wait for it to come to game pass
unless you know you're just trying to
save your money right now because
i've played it a little bit so far i'm a
couple of hours in you're about to see
the first hour of it here in this video
and i'm having a blast so far so i
definitely recommend it hope you guys
enjoy the video as always thank you all
so much for watching
okay people of the internet here we are
with death's door another entry in
our let's play series i've been looking
forward to this game i've heard a lot of
good things but didn't read all that
much about the specific mechanics so
all this is going to be totally new to
me and i can't wait to see what it has
in store so we're just gonna dive right
in here
looks like we need to create a file
we'll just go right there from the top
and here we go
now arriving at reaping commission
headquarters sharon the bus driver is
talking right now end of the line
left stick to move all right that's me
uh looks kind of like a little
bird
i think
so we just
oh inspect
click seems like the phone isn't
connected to anything a little pay phone
here oh goodness
so that was the uh right trigger that
did that
oh and then left trigger pulls out my
bow and arrow right there okay
i assume the game's about to tell me
that but
you know how it goes sometimes you can i
fall off okay that's important to know
we need to go ahead i think i just lost
a health point
top left but it's important to establish
that from the beginning
all right so we know that we could fall
off
let's see can we destroy these boxes
over here no
so far it hasn't told me anything except
using l to move
hello there
vega says ain't got no souls
ain't got no shinies ain't got no
worries
all right then
no souls no shinies no worries okay
dude that atmosphere man
i'm loving just the visuals of this game
mostly black and white and then you get
kind of like the little pops of color
right here with the sword and then the
neon lights right there
can we go up to this yes we can inspect
ticket office is closed
gone to fix a broken pipe back in three
to four years
management okay
i guess it must be a pretty severely
broken pipe it's gonna take up three to
four years let's talk to this dude here
ball plart
head of security yeah you're clear move
it along bud
all right
well he said i was clear
even though we got the x there
hall of doors reaping commission
headquarters
okay so with the game
title being death's door
you would assume that it's going to have
something to do with the afterlife right
and that's kind of the vibe that i'm
getting here early on i'm gonna go talk
to this guy
this is badger the reaper better get
moving don't want to be late right
i don't know i guess not
but i've got three different paths that
i can go to i don't think we can go here
yeah he's got us blocked off
but we can go any one of these three
ways i'm going to take the left path
first
see where this leads we got a giant
statue here
and then just an area to fall off okay
so we don't want to go that way
oh okay this is all good to know
it's like a little roll right here
i'm actually using a playstation
controller
oh
whoops down the two bars film
i'm using a playstation controller so
the button prompts me throw me off a
little bit
i don't know that i like having this
button be my dodge
so let's see if we can go here into uh
yeah change up the bindings here
so for my dodge
i think i'd like for that to be
circle
which is b for xbox
shoot back
is currently on
so we got aim left trigger that's all
good charge attack
do i want attack so a is actually x on
the the dual shot controller
trying to think do i want the attack to
be on x or would i rather it be on
square
let's just keep it like this for now
we'll see how this goes whoops
escape cancel
[Music]
all right so
okay so the way it is now we got this
right here and then circle does my roll
i like that feel a lot better then we
got this little
so x is my attack
i kind of think i want to have that as a
square though let's go ahead and change
that one and then we'll be set to go
here
okay i think we got the controls
somewhere that that feel right given
that i'm using a playstation controller
instead i just had to hop into the menu
a little bit and tweak that
chandler the handler well well well
look who showed up for work no worms for
you because only the early bird catches
never mind
anyway it's your lucky day i actually
have a soul for you to reap okay there
we go so we're getting a little bit
of insight into
what the story is here so i guess my
character is a reaper of soul so we have
someone who's died apparently
and not just any soul a giant soul think
of the commission on that i hope you
haven't forgotten your training stay on
your talons giant souls don't often go
peacefully dropping in your door for you
now
okay dropping in my door
where is my door oh right there
oh man it makes me think about monsters
inc we gotta go through the door here
with the soul that size you might even
be able to afford some time off
but remember
oh gosh your door will remain open until
you return with your designated
soul
while your door is opened you will be
mortal and you will age so get it done
quickly
okay
reaping souls to power the doors just so
we can reap more souls and the cycle
repeats forever
interesting so
reaping the souls is what powers these
doors just so we can reap more souls and
the cycle repeats forever the rat race
eh
anyway get to it and be careful
if you die it's going to be a lot of
paperwork and i don't have the time
okay so my character it's not really
clear
what sort of being i am
right now apparently i'm immortal but
when i go up here
you have to become mortal while you're
there oh boy i love typing can't get
enough of it okay
how about you sir
darwin the vault keeper oh he's just
asleep over here
vault keeper
he just has to be big and guard the door
i need to start making sure i read the
names of the characters agatha the
typist over here seriously cause any
havoc you like out there i've got to
cover just get me some more of those
sweet sweet documents to verify and type
up
all right
dude there's so much to explore just in
this little area
i know where they wanted me to go they
want me to go
right over there to my door right but
then this
this elevator over here
you guys see this like it kind of
yeah it's right here
it's just to take me up same spot that's
kind of weird you can just walk around
[Music]
oh now they said i had a giant soul
that door is huge up there look at all
the doors in the background though
all right so that's the one where we
need to go i'm just gonna check and see
what's over here on the left side
can i destroy this nope
okay so r2 we already established that's
like the little charge attack oh
sunbrella can i pick this up
you found a discarded umbrella it's just
the thing to keep your feathers dry in
grim weather you can equip it from the
weapons menu
oh wow i'm glad i came over here then so
let's see we've got
our inventory here
three slots for giant souls
four crystal shards
okay so the green ones are vitality
collect four shards to fill your soul
with vigor raising your vitality and
then the pink ones here magic crystal
shards collect four shards to fill your
soul power
raising your magic capacity whoops
and then we've got three spaces for
giant souls here weapons so we've got
the reaper sword a standard issue sword
for reaping souls
and then the umbrella that we just
picked up
so
i don't know dude i kind of want to just
equip it here
[Music]
but let's see is it it does .5 damage
three swings 2.5 range swing time of 0.4
so this damage is one the range on the
sword is better
i don't know the range is actually
actually the same so yeah this is
interesting
not very useful in comp and in combat
but it will keep your feathers dry and
bad weather okay so if it ever starts
raining i gotta remember that i do in
fact have
an umbrella that i can pull out
good to know okay
can i shoot dude do i have any arrows
yet
no
oh i do
oh very cool
so it's
the way i have it mapped right now
circle to shoot the arrows
all right so let's head to my door
oh man i wish i could have got some more
health though before i go in here
rolling off the side twice
oh
the grove of spirits assigned soul
location
and you can see that uh it is colorful
now because we have stepped into the
mortal world and they did say that i
really need to be quick about it i don't
know how
uh serious they are with that like
is it actually going to affect
the result of the game or is it just
kind of more of a story thing like hey
look at these little dudes
are you friendly
okay i guess we can't attack
all right so that
triggered the switch there
yeah it looks like these guys aren't
enemies because
i took a swing at them and they still
didn't attack me
all right this one here is interesting
am i gonna have to use my bow and arrow
here most likely
oh goodness
what they're following me
hello little guys
dude you know before the end of the
level they're gonna turn on me watch
they're totally gonna turn on me
they're they're lulling me to sleep
right now
oh are those the pink crystals
let's see
no i was about to say that would have
been way too easy
oh they just come back too
these little mushrooms
look like little mushrooms i don't
really know what they are but
all right so we got another switch right
here
okay and that just takes us back to the
beginning which we do not want to go
through that door right now
is this the soul possibly
demonic forest spirit okay
it's like a little tutorial
[Music]
yeah get that charge attack in there
do they have a health bar i'm not seeing
a health bar anywhere
all right i gotta remember that dodge
there's no sprint from what i can
tell i was about to say can i still
attack with my
you do have to kind of charge it up a
little bit so i can't i can't sort of
rapid fire it
oh jeez
it's not expecting this
i think we just need to run away
it's tutorial
i don't think it's meant to be too
difficult
at least not yet we'll see if they kind
of like crank up the difficulty
am i out of arrows nothing was happening
that time i tried to do it
[Music]
oh
okay okay
there we go i'm starting to think this
looks like she could just go on forever
with this
okay now i've got my arrows back too i'm
not sure why i couldn't use them there
oh that actually hit me
oh no i only have one life
or one hit left
yikes
first death
i blame it on me rolling off in the
beginning
okay we got full health now oh and
actually oh that's really nice so i
don't have to reopen that that stays
open okay good deal good deal
all right we're ready for this now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah that dodge you can actually cover
quite a bit of ground for that little
roll
see like right there man you really can
get out of the way
oh dude i'm out i'm out of arrows again
i don't understand
maybe it like has to charge up or
something
see if they're ready again
yep
oh dude i bet it's tied somehow yeah
there we go see as i hit
in the top left under my health that
magic meter is kind of refilling
so it doesn't take long for the magic
meter every hit it seemed to increase
with each hit
all right nice that wasn't too bad
what
what was that
why'd that dude attack me
well i've got 100 something bottom right
there
100 of something not really sure what it
is
now these little dudes
still following me around
you guys are gonna go back with me okay
let's go just come on in
oh they didn't come with
lost cemetery forbidden region
well i don't know what just happened to
me if that was
supposed to happen i mean obviously it's
supposed to happen within the game i
mean
but like is that what normally happens
to my character when they go out on
these uh
reapings
creeping the souls
we're definitely not back where we
started this looks like you know just a
a massive graveyard look at all these
graves
that looks like the dude that came up
behind me
okay nothing there
so yeah i am limited see watch well i
don't really want to waste one right now
but i'm pretty sure when i use this
arrow
it will uh take away one of those little
magic
kind of diamond looking things
underneath my health the health is in
green and then underneath the white oh
what's this
you collected a life seed planting one
of these in a green pot will yield soul
fruit which can be consumed to restore
your health okay fortunately
after i died they gave me all my health
back so i don't really need any right
now i'm maxed out
but i guess i can just keep this
indefinitely let's see if it appears in
my inventory no
not under shiny things
interesting
interesting i guess it's just uh
contextual if i come upon one
hopefully
i can
thought i could walk over there for a
second guess not okay let's climb up
here
yeah so i'm assuming that that
big enemy that i fought was the
the soul that i'm after
but now i'm not so sure
[Music]
how do we get up there
this game is absolutely gorgeous by the
way i love the art style
developed by acid nerve and published by
devolver digital
and this dude so you got a key
oh my goodness his body's still laying
there
okay
activate
oh wow it's a door
but do i want to take the door
here's another door right here you
collected a massive soul energy soul
energy can be spent in the hall of doors
on reaper upgrades
okay can be spent in the hall of doors
on reaper
okay so we can't get through there right
now that's probably gonna be something
that we come back to later maybe with
some kind of fire ability
you guys know how it is it's always the
fire right that uh
burns away the webs so we clearly need
the key to get into there but what else
do we have around here
let's check out this right side over
here
[Music]
oh is there a sign okay let's read this
this way to the summit
not sure if we need to go to the summit
or not oh there's another one of these
little orbs though
now walk under here
oh nothing there okay
so we've kind of got our bearings now we
know where we need to go
gonna have to go through that door
what is this little splotch of red right
here you think that's blood from
fighting this dude
i do want to check up here really quick
to make sure there's not another
path that i missed
i have heard that it is really worth
your while to explore in this game now
i'm still very early obviously so there
could be certain things that
just doesn't really uh
you know they're not opening up the game
so much just yet okay i could also go
down that way
let's let's do this first
oh it was blood dude when we fought him
trying to space out that little uh
charge attack just right
all right so we don't really need to
restore health
because i think i see
oh well there we go
just gotta say i don't really need to
restore health oh and so destroying all
those enemies openness right here oh man
look at this guy
oh
okay this is locked
i bet we gotta destroy enemies again
see now okay there's that seed i could
plant now i wonder how many it restores
let's go ahead and try to clear all this
out first
oh i knew that
okay that one's down that one's down
dude it's kind of creepy how they just
stay on the ground with the blood lying
right beside them
okay so this just unlocked something big
right here is that the key
that is that was the key
and then it opened the ladder right
there okay before we do that though
let's go back to our health
plant the seed
see how many it gives us
now i wonder if that will come back
after a time
or if i have to put down like another
scene
now i had assumed that we were gonna
need to go through that door
because i thought the key would be in
there but now
i don't know let's see if it'll let us
go back here
okay we can't go back through all right
and it does it leads us back here
into the hall of doors uh darwin the
vault keeper little crow
do i sense a glut of soul energy come
here and you can trade in those souls to
gain an edge in combat
all right so this door stays this door
also stays all right so and the label is
over the top there grove of spirits
and then over this one right here lost
cemetery just making sure you guys could
still see that
got the webcam in the bottom left of the
screen i think that's actually the best
spot for this game
all right let's chat with this darwin
guy here welcome to the soul vault would
you like to increase your combat
abilities why yes i would okay so we've
got strength dexterity haste and magic
okay so strength probably going to be
pretty self-explanatory reaper's ability
to wield melee weapons raising this will
increase the damage done with melee
weapons as well as their reach
so not only does it increase the damage
but it also
extends the reach that's pretty powerful
dexterity reaper's ability to attack
with speed and precision raising this
will allow the reaper to charge their
melee and range attacks faster and
increase the speed at which the melee
attacks can be chained together so that
one cost 400 actually all of them cost
400
so we don't have enough for anything
haste the reaper's speed and grace of
movement raising this will give the
reaper a greater base speed faster
dodges and less cool down time between
dodges
magic the reaper's ability to harness
magical powers raising this will
increase the damage done with magic
spells and ranged abilities
yeah i feel like all those are going to
be pretty useful um
i feel like strength is probably where
you need to go first strength or maybe
haste
although
if i want to play it safe and and stay
range for a while which actually it
makes me think is there any difficulty
setting in this game
i don't remember seeing one it didn't
like give me the option or anything so
i guess not no difficulty setting all
right so i don't have enough for
anything anyway but it was good to come
back and
get a look at where things are
you have one new item in your inventory
what in the world steam
what are you talking about
what are you talking about get off my
screen
all right so now we do still have that
key though oh and all the enemies come
back
and also the flower that gives us health
[Music]
looks like both of those came back
all right so let's use this key right
here to unlock
head up this uh let's say stairs the
ladder
head up the ladder here oh goodness
oh no i was trying to blast with the
arrow
oh goodness another one came out of the
door
i keep wanting to like hit a block
button or something
from what i found out so far i don't
think there is a block i think it's i
think it's dodge
you got a bob and weave you know
oh yikes
okay this guy right here
gotta get him to run into a wall or
something and then
or you could just knock him out with the
arrow
you can hit him in the right moment
oh there he goes
[Music]
oh i think he got stuck
you see that he wasn't moving for a
second there
oh they ran into each other
oh and you can destroy that too
all right one more
oh you can plant a seed right there wait
do i keep that seed
hold up hold up hold up because i did
not get another seed
okay yeah it won't let me i was about to
say why i was i'm surprised it even
popped up
oh my goodness is there any reason for
me to destroy these things like the
little eyeball rolling around
doesn't seem like there's anything in
there
all right well that was kind of crazy
right there
those doors just started appearing out
of nowhere and these enemies dropping in
all right let's go to the ladder over
here
let's see where to next i mean i could
go back to that flower and get my one
bar of health but i think i'm okay for
now maybe if i lose another one i might
consider it okay this clearly is going
to be important later on
maybe not right now
all right let's head up the stairs right
here
more gravestones
whoa look at this dude
stead
i want to say stonehead steadhone the
gravedigger
ah a reaper
my time in this world is over
[Music]
wait what
wait no am i supposed
is it you am i supposed to kill you
[Music]
no still here and still very much alive
perhaps try a bit of a run-up
this dude
roll with a and press
wait what
oh my goodness
i'm sorry it's not your fault it happens
to everyone i'm afraid i am burdened
with unending life i can't explain it
and i've spent untold years seeking an
answer my name is steadhone i am the
keeper of graves on this sacred mountain
oh and if you do find yourself
strengthened somehow feel free to try
and kill me again
oh that's hilarious
he's like nope still not unfortunately
i'm still alive
the dude wants me to kill him but he's
just so powerful
you're welcome to stop by anytime you
like reaper okay
i wonder is my name reaper or is that
just like my job oh here's
dug a grave right here
guess we can't fall in that we already
established we can fall off the side as
we did earlier
oh wait this one was lighting up a bit
here lies a guardian of the door a
preserver of order and a home to stray
souls
interesting
by the way if any of you out there are
interested in picking up this game
right now it is only on xbox and pc
so
i think
it might eventually come to playstation
switch i don't know
and then there's been some talk about
will it ever come to game pass
because it is not on game pass at launch
i could see it down the road but i think
if uh if you're looking forward to
playing this game or if this looks cool
to you
don't wait man support the developers
definitely pick this up i'm still
obviously way early
but i'm really enjoying it so far it's
only 20 bucks too so
i think it's about from what i was
reading about a six seven hour
experience
in total
[Music]
all right so this loops back around
oh wait no this is not i've not been in
this area before okay this way to the
stranded sailor
francisco
this simple structure has a twin
a hidden secret lies within
[Music]
okay this hidden structure has a twin
you would think it would be like right
here on this side
like opposite that one is what i was
thinking
or maybe like right in here somewhere
maybe charge it up
nope
okay well
that seems blocked off over there is
there anything i can do to interact with
this
nope doesn't seem like it
all right
okay so we'll try to remember that if we
come to the twin of that
tower right there
that apparently there's a secret
somewhere
all right let's head back this way okay
so there's there's a little one of those
orbs up there i feel like we passed a
ladder earlier didn't we
we came up that ladder right there
that's just gonna fall off we don't want
to do that we already know what happens
what happens there
all right there's that guy he's like hey
try to kill me we can't kill him
you know about the little gravestone
over there okay let's try this door is
there anything we can do here
nope
nope nope nope negative negative
negative okay well
what did this sign say again maybe this
is some kind of hint
eli is a guardian of the door
preservative order and a home to trace
stray souls jeez i already read it once
okay oh
all it tells us is that he lies there
okay this kind of looks like a little
hidden path oh
look at that
look at that man
okay how about this one
nope all right we'll climb up then
let's head over here
i think this is gonna bring us where
that orb is yep called it
okay so now we're over uh we're at 447
so we could buy one of the upgrades now
but all that really did was was take us
to this spot
and it seems like that's the only thing
you can do here so i don't know that
that's going to help us
progress forward now it looks like
clearly there's something
over here it's kind of blurred out
because i think it's on a lower level
oh wait is this another one of those
like little camera tricks where
could be a hidden path or something you
know
all right what if i shoot my arrow
nothing okay
all right well
good that we discovered that
i'm gonna head back down here
put on these steps right here
okay so we do have a couple of different
ways that we can we could try to go here
there's this one
got a very large statue up there
another sign
this way to the summit okay well maybe
we need to go to the summit
you've seen a couple different signs for
the summit now
all right but before i do this see i'm
super oh man
this is why like games with branching
paths i'm always like wait a second wait
a second though
and you never know which ones like the
path to progress oh goodness
oh okay so two hits max on those guys
and then you need to back away
that's how i'm just gonna do one
all right so it takes three hits to kill
him right now at my current is that one
of the seeds
yeah i think it is
so bottom right corner the seed pops up
wait really that's all that was down
here
just to get that seed
uh i mean i guess that is helpful i can
go replenish my health
where was it
it's not right here oh it was back this
way wasn't it
i do think rolling's a little bit faster
and the cooldown is
pretty short on it
so you can you can basically just spam
it
wait where was it at was it down here
with this guy
oh my goodness it's forever away
oh it's forever away
i thought there was another one though
i'm gonna totally forget how we even got
up here okay yeah there's that spot
is this where i fought all those guys oh
here it is right here
okay so not too bad
all right we're gonna go ahead and
consume
give us back our health
all right so now we're gonna take that
big long path which apparently heads to
the summit
oh no not that way
not that way
all right up the ladder then back over
to the left here
[Music]
down the stairs
and this way okay now we're back
now we're back where we need to be
we already know the sign talks about the
summit all right go across this really
long bridge here
[Music]
and see if we finally reach the summit
oh there's a lever though
push level
i don't know if you guys knew this or
not when you're playing a game
and and you have the option to push the
lever
i feel like you should usually push the
lever not always though
there are some games that try to try to
mess with you like that but
most of the time
when you see that lever you need to
press it
okay well here we go with the branching
paths again
oh wait that just leads me back
oh
okay this is where we already were
before yes yes yes
and that's the door that takes me back
well you know what i mean since i'm down
here right
since i'm down here i might as well go
ahead and jump back to the little hub
world
and we'll go ahead and go down here and
we'll upgrade i think i'm gonna do
strength first of all
with strength
i might actually try and max out both
strength and uh what was the other one
called haste
are you sure you want to buy this
upgrade because it looks like they have
five upgrades each
next one costs 600 okay
so by the time you're done you know
they're gonna be costing well over a
thousand i would i would guess
[Music]
still locked over there just double
checking
just peeking around here see if anything
has changed in this area
all right back to the lost cemetery now
we know the enemies are going to be back
but
we can head straight up this ladder here
and that that guy at the top of the
ladder is really the only one that
we'll need to worry about
oh i missed i miss with that little uh
charge
all attack let's go this way now
oh
okay so that automatically lowers
and then if i step back on
very nice okay
i was wondering if it was like automatic
or what now look at this over here you
know that we're definitely gonna need to
break this down
the question is how okay so none of the
charge tax work on it
so it's gonna require some other
look at that man
look at that
all right so that's what they were
talking about with the exploration in
this game it's really important to
explore let's see what we can find here
oh
prey at shrine
what's this gonna do
oh something's coming out the ancient
shrine offers you a shard from a
vitality crystal collecting four will
raise your vitality bone its limit okay
very nice so
if you're a zelda fan this is
essentially like a heart piece right
there
and yeah crystal shard right there one
out of four and i also need them for
magic as well
all right well that was definitely worth
the detour then
so we just need what three more now to
upgrade our health which i assume would
just give us another node because we got
four nodes right now
all right so back up we go
[Music]
and we gotta remember don't forget about
this
hopefully there's a way to destroy that
oh goodness
there we go
oh yeah that's right i upped my strength
so
oh darn it
yeah so these enemies
those those one guys used to take three
hits but i haven't seen any of them or
yeah i did see that one didn't i
i don't remember how many hits he took
all right took out both of them
[Music]
pick that up right there oh my goodness
this is a huge drop
leads to the big door before i do that
though
is there a way i can like fall off and
and immediately attack this guy
[Music]
wait really it still takes three hits
they're like just take our word for it
it's doing more damage
i'm sure it is but
evidently that means not very much
because i was thinking i might lower it
to uh i'm gonna save the seed actually
i was thinking it might lower its two
hits oh look at this guy
dude that looks just like one of the
enemies from uh zelda
wiz rogues that what they're called
oh man this is bad news if i uh
i run out of arrows right
only got one arrow left
i should have hit him with the sword on
that one shouldn't i
there he is that's probably close enough
so yeah one hit immediately gave me one
of my arrows back
oh no oh no
out of the way dodge him
oh
he disappeared just in time
oh yeah it's definitely better if you
can get up and hit those guys
they go down a lot faster
and this little dude
oh that's pretty cool that the
shooting him with the arrow immediately
knocks him over
oh goodness
oh got him with the charge got him with
the charge
where are you gonna appear
right there
boom
oh i thought that guy
i thought that guy was gonna hit me for
sure oh got him
both with the charge attack all right i
probably shouldn't be
going so crazy man i only got two bars
of health
all right the little wiz rose guys are
not that difficult
those guys that kind of charge you
you have to pay more attention on them
for sure
or they will make you pay for it all
right so we do have we got a couple of
those seeds
all right make sure there's nothing over
here
anything hidden there that i need to do
i don't think so
all right so we could always backtrack
and plant okay let's do that actually
i don't really like dropping because if
i get hit again then you're all of a
sudden oh it's just right there
yeah not that far
all right so full health again
let's go back now and head up the ladder
anything up here what we need to do
anything at all
another lever
we know what to do with those
all right and it does open both sides
all right wasn't there a branching path
back here
oh no yeah remember there was that big
long drop
off this way to the summit
oh wait this is back uh
okay yeah yeah yeah this is back over
here
all right hold on though
because i don't think i can get to
i think i have to go this way to get to
that really big drop off
because i do want to see what's down
there
nope not that drop off we got to keep
going
yeah this way this way
yeah look at this man see if you take
fall damage no okay
all right good to know that as well all
right so we've seen a couple of these
statues like this
almost looks like their head is a
keyhole
see that
so i don't know if there's gonna be
something later on that we get
to interact with those because i feel
like there's got to be a point to that
and then obviously we're going to
we're going to be going through that
door at some point
but it looks like as of now there's
there's actually nothing that we can do
down here
so
was it a waste of time
i don't think so
i don't think so because now i know
i have that peace of mind you guys a
peace of mind is so important
see now i know i didn't miss some huge
upgrade
all right so now we head back and then
we'll go up top and we've unlocked a lot
of little shortcuts so if we
do happen to die at some point here in
the near future
oh look at this though
how do i get over there
oh levers over there on the side i think
it's going to involve that somehow
maybe it loops back around
okay so this is what we just opened and
we want to go this way
i knew it man i knew something was going
to happen as soon as i crossed over that
i thought it was gonna be the doors
opening up again
okay is that a building walking toward
me
guardian of the door
oh goodness
okay
how do we attack this guy
okay he could fly too
all right so he's he's vulnerable it's
not like i mean because you look at him
and he looks like he's just encased in a
pretty uh strong shield there
[Music]
dodge
dodge
[Music]
oh oh oh he came quick with that one
i guess you know i could also roll in to
do damage as well
oh yeah we do not want that
[Music]
man that ranged upgrade would be super
nice too
[Music]
oh okay he's going back up again
levitating
get those shots in before he turns on
the laser
i think it's moving a little bit faster
this time
oh i'm out of arrows
oh that hit got me
he's got to be getting close and i do
not want to die
because i feel like we've done really
well on this fight
yeah so i'm going to go back
do some ranged attacks on him
you know what i haven't been doing i
haven't been doing any charge oh no
one hit
oh he's pulling out all the stops now
i'm gonna be really cautious right now
oh no dude no
did we get him
let's go baby
let's go
yeah i was being really cautious at the
end there but i kind of feel like you
have to and
you're down to that final health bar
all right is that it i don't get
anything
no reward
where's my reward
i don't know what these things are for
all right so at least we get to do this
boom
all right let's see where that says this
way to the summit dude we're we've got
to be getting so close to the summit
this way to the overgrown ruins okay but
how do we
how do we open that up right there
and i really do not like going up here
without oh wait is this a little secret
spot right here nope it's not
i don't really like the idea of going up
here without
getting my health back first but
i would hope that there's a place up
here
another lever okay let's pull that
what just happened
oh wait
oh another shortcut unlocked let's go
dude okay so hold on then
there's the guy up there
so i think down here
yes there's another plant
[Music]
all right
[Music]
will they follow me up the ladder let's
see
oh no they don't
they don't volley up the ladder
[Music]
all right so now we can just go right
back up here
that's good though i was really just
concerned about health that was the main
thing so i think what that lever did is
drop this gate right here i just didn't
i didn't see it when it happened on
screen
okay so now we can go up this way and we
gotta be getting close to the summit we
keep hearing about the summit
and another little tricky
tricky spot right here how do you get
over to that
maybe we don't have the ability just yet
see i don't even need to do that now
because i just
[Music]
maxed out my health
all right nothing we can do there
okay that feels like the summit is that
way
let's double check this area first
make sure there aren't any secrets that
are easily accessible here okay so we
got a keyhole right there we got the key
right here oh this drops us down here
[Music]
and that's it there's nothing here
it's a little odd oh wait there is
something right here
oh here we go almost missed that you
found some incense this stuff smells
very strong
see if our inventory gives us any more
an incense used in ancient rituals to
aid the dead in their passage to the
next life and to mask the stench of
corpses in the embalming process
the label on the side reads instance of
atonement perfect for masking that
rotting corp smell
interesting okay so we're masking that
rotting corpse smell
trying to think of when would be a time
i don't know maybe there's a moment in
the game where
um because it looks like i don't know if
i can stack these if i can have multiple
or what but
looks like we just have the one right
now
so it's just uh it's not like it gives
you multiple or anything
all right
but maybe you can get more maybe you can
i don't know
okay so
i don't know if that was important or
not to get that but we got it
can't open that yet can't get access to
that yet so we gotta go this way man
we gotta go up the mountain
this has got to be the summit right
that looked like the dude who walked in
behind me
bashed me in the back of the head
without me looking
the gray crow okay oh hello fledgling
sorry about the crack on the head but i
needed that so excu excuse me
you see i was a reaper just like you
years ago my assignment evaded capture
it took many months to track it down to
this location
upon arrival i discovered it somehow
passed through this door
inconceivable
do you know where we are fledgling
oh
oh
okay
gotcha that's where we are
the end point for all life
i thought it was just a
legend as you know all doors are powered
by the energy of souls perhaps with a
truly monumental amount of power even
this one could be forced open
sadly the soul i stole from you was not
enough
[Music]
i'm afraid that our fates are very much
intertwined now fledgling but with your
assignment incomplete your death is now
an inevitability
[Music]
excuse me dude
so what you're essentially telling me
great crow is you just killed me
am i stuck mortal forever now
without the soul that now resides behind
this door you are trapped just like me
what a punk dude
he did that on purpose
totally did that on purpose however
fortune may still smile upon yeah you
did this to trick me into helping not
even trick me into helping you to coerce
me into helping you grey crow
this cursed land is hidden to the reaper
somehow untouched by the laws of nature
the creatures here have the potential to
live vastly beyond their ears growing
ever larger and more powerful
i know of three such beings on these
isles whose combined soul energy could
grant us the power to wedge this door
open
to the north lives an old witch obsessed
with escaping the clutches of death
beyond the forest to the east a
self-proclaimed king rules over the
ruins of a flooded cathedral
and atop the mountain to the west a
beast of i started to say a beautiful
a beast of untold years primal and
vicious with no want or desire
i'm truly sorry to have entangled you
fletcher
i don't believe him i don't i don't
believe him
i i don't
i just don't
but at my advance yours my body grows
weary
your path is your own now
either venture into the wilds and reap
those giant souls or choose inaction
and suffer the same fate as this old
fool
ah
punk
do you wish for guidance on where to
head next uh sure yeah
i suggest you head north there lives an
old witch obsessed with escaping death
okay wait is this northen right here
can i go in this door oh no that's death
store
that's death store we can't get in there
without powering it up so is he just
giving up now
you're you're giving up dude
oh now it drops excellent
we'll take the key
and then we'll head over to the witch's
abode
all right unlock the gate
and let's see what the sign over here
says
this way to the earn witch's mansion all
right
guys i think that is going to be a great
place for us to stop in this first
episode i really hope you enjoyed this
make sure you give it a thumbs up on the
video and i'll catch you again next time
guys as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon